what's up guys so as you guys already
know GPU mining is very popular right
now and also very profitable if you do
it right as you can see GPU money is a
great way to make some side cash or even
a lot of cash so why should you stop and
chill for a bit before jumping on to buy
that next set of graphics cards for your
insane setup well here's why a better
option for mining is expected to come
out very soon that is specifically
designed for mining so it should perform
exponentially better than gaming or into
graphics cards as a result it would be
better if you hold off investing that
10k into our x5 80s right now because a
much superior option is coming out in a
very imminent future and not to mention
at a much more reasonable price than
what our x58 is retail for right now so
what is this new GPU who is releasing it
when is it coming and why should you
care well it's coming out from none
other than Nvidia themselves and it is
codenamed tyranny he is expected to
reveal this project on March 26th at GT
C and then tearing itself is expected to
be released on April 12th so right
around the corner
if you're a minor you should care
because for the same price you'll be
able to build a much more profitable set
up and also you would want to be able to
pick it up as soon as possible so that
you are not forced to pay much higher
prices to the stock shortages or wait a
few months extra for prices to simply
return to MSRP simply because you didn't
do your research and you didn't realize
that there is a much better mining GPU
until the embargo date is released and
tearing is coming out and your whole
recommended tab is flooded performance
or review videos and when you go to pick
up your own attorney you realize you
missed out a big so if you are
interested in turing then make sure to
keep track of its latest rumors and news
and be up to date on it next what should
you expect out of Turin well it's
obviously going to be much superior to
current generation graphics cards in
terms of mining because this is
specifically built for that scenario and
why would people buy it if it didn't do
so ask for specs the Turing is still
mostly in dark and I still don't know
what
you can expect out of it if you guys are
mining nerds and you know all about this
then make sure to help us stupid gamers
out by posting it in down in a comments
below about how you think Turing will
perform so that anyone who might have
been concerned to start mining well know
what to expect out of it if you guys are
interested in why it is expected for
Turing to be a mining GPU and some more
information on Turing then make sure to
check out my dedicated video on it
so overall guys if you are planning on
expanding your mining setup or building
a new mining setup from scratch then
quit before it's too late and you've
invest a lot of money into the arcs
series or Nvidia and then you're
struggling to sell their cards you paw
and you can't buy more without selling
them and then you're just stuck so I
recommend and I use wait and see what
NVIDIA has to offer before you make any
rash decisions but that's pretty much
all I have for you guys this time make
sure to post your thoughts in the
comments down below this I do read all
my comments and I am curious as to what
you guys think for example how do you
think Turing will affect gamers and what
do you think will happen to
cryptocurrency prices after the release
of this card make sure to post would you
guys think and if you liked this video
make sure to drop a like on it and hit
that subscribe button if you want to see
more videos just like this and hit up
bail notification to be notified every
time I post a new video but until next
time bye